- What's up, believe nation?
It's Evan, my one word is
believe, and I believe in people
more than they believe in themselves.
And my sincere hope is that
if you see in yourself what I see in you,
you'll be able to go off
and change the planet.
Now we started the Mentor Me series
to try to learn from people
who've done a lot more than us.
And by hanging around them,
and absorbing their wisdom
and their knowledge.
some of their mindsets, their beliefs,
their attitudes, their
way of seeing the world,
seep into us to help us become
the best version of ourselves.
So today we're going to
learn from Simon Sinek
and how to start with Why.
Mentor me, Simon.
(inspirational music)
- The Why was born out of pain.
It was never an academic
or commercial exercise,
it was born at a time in my life
many years ago, ten years ago,
where I had lost my passion
for what I was doing.
I owned my own small business,
I was living the American dream.
Superficially, my life was fantastic.
And yet, I didn't want to
wake up and do it again,
and I was embarrassed by that.
You know, who am I to
complain about my life?
My life seemed perfect and yet I hated it,
and so I kept it to myself.
Every ounce of my being,
all the energy that I had
was invested pretending
that I was happier,
more successful, and more
in control than I felt.
And it was debilitating, quite frankly.
Strange things start to
happen when you put yourself
in that cycle and the
stress starts to build.
You start to become paranoid.
So for example, I was convinced
that my employees hated me.
I didn't go out much, and it was really,
it was really a bad time.
It was a confluence of events,
and I made this discovery
that every single
organization on the planet,
even our own careers,
always function on the same three levels.
What we do, how we do
it, and why we do it.
And it was based on the biology
of human decision making.
It wasn't some highfalutin
management theory,
it was based on brain stuff.
And I realized I knew what I did,
I was good at it, and I knew how I did it.
I could tell you what was different
or special about the way I did things,
but I couldn't tell
you why I was doing it.
That was the missing piece,
you have to have all three.
I became obsessed with
this thing called the Why.
I figured out how to find my
Why and it restored my passion
to levels I had never experienced before.
And more importantly, I figured out
how to help others find theirs.
And I did what anyone would do.
When you discover something beautiful,
you share it with your friends.
And my friends started making
crazy life changes themselves,
and they started finding
happiness and passion
that they'd never experienced before.
It was me solving my own problem,
that happened to help others
solve it for them, too.
And people just kept inviting
me and I just kept saying yes.
I was making huge decisions
that were really easy to make.
Like I shut down my office
and started over again
because I realized the
business I had built
was so inconsistent with my Why.
All my friends thought
I went out of business
and they were worried about me.
It was the easiest decision I ever made.
In other words, when you know
your Why the filter is clear.
It's not like there are options.
The option is obvious,
there's only one option.
Share, give, inspire.
As it turns out, there's a pattern.
As it turns out, all the
great and inspiring leaders
and organizations in the
world, whether it's Apple,
or Martin Luther King,
or the Wright brothers.
They all think, act, and
communicate the exact same way,
and it's the complete
opposite to everyone else.
All I did was codify it.
And it's probably the
world's simplest idea.
I call it The Golden Circle.
Why, how, what.
This little idea explains
why some organizations
and some leaders are able to
inspire, where others aren't.
Let me define the terms really quickly.
Every single person,
every single organization
on the planet knows what they do, 100%.
Some know how they do it.
Whether you call it your
differentiating value proposition
or your proprietary process, or your USP,
but very, very few people or organizations
know why they do what they do.
And by Why I don't mean to make a profit.
That's a result, it's always a result.
By Why I mean what's your purpose,
what's your cause, what's your belief.
Why does your organization exist?
Why do you get out of bed in the morning,
and why should anyone care?
Well as a result, the way
we think, the way we act,
the way we communicate is from
the outside in, it's obvious.
We go from the clearest
thing to the fuzziest thing.
But the inspired leaders and
the inspired organizations,
regardless of their size,
regardless of their industry,
all think, act, and communicate
from the inside out.
Sometimes you can give
somebody all the facts
and the figures, and they say,
"I know what all the
facts and details say,
"but it just doesn't feel right."
Why would we use that verb,
"it doesn't feel right?"
Because the part of the brain
that controls decision-making,
doesn't control language.
And the best we can muster
up is, "I don't know,
"it just doesn't feel right."
Or sometimes you say you're
leading with your heart
or you're leading with your soul.
Well, I hate to break it to you,
those aren't the body parts
controlling your behavior.
It's all happening here
in your limbic brain,
the part of the brain that
controls decision making
and not language.
But if you don't know
why you do what you do,
and people respond to
then how will anybody, how
will you ever get people to,
to vote for you or buy something from you,
or more importantly, be loyal,
and want to be a part of
what it is that you do.
Again, the goal is not just to sell people
who need what you have, the goal is
to sell to people who
believe what you believe.
The goal is not just to
hire people who need a job,
it's to hire people who
believe what you believe.
I always say that if you,
hire people just because they can do a job
they'll work for your money,
but if you hire people who
believe what you believe
they work for you with
blood, and sweat, and tears.
And nowhere else is there
a better example of this
than with the Wright brothers.
Most people don't know about
Samuel Pierpont Langley.
And back in the early 20th century,
the pursuit of powered man flight
was like the dotcom of the
day, everybody was trying it.
And Samuel Pierpont Langley had
what we assume to be
the recipe for success.
I mean, even now we ask
people why did your product
or why did your company fail,
and people always give you
the same permutation of
the same three things.
Under-capitalized, the wrong
people, bad market conditions,
it's always the same three things.
So let's explore that.
Samuel Pierpont Langley was given $50,000
by the war department to
figure out this flying machine.
Money was no problem.
He held a seat at Harvard,
and worked at the Smithsonian,
and was extremely well-connected.
He knew all the big minds of the day.
He hired the best minds money could find
and the market conditions were fantastic.
The New York Times followed
him around everywhere,
and everyone was rooting for Langley.
Then how come we've never heard
of Samuel Pierpont Langley?
A few hundred miles away in Dayton, Ohio,
Orville and Wilbur Wright.
They had none of what we consider
to be the recipe for success.
They had no money, they
paid for their dream
with the proceeds from their bicycle shop.
Not a single person on
the Wright brothers' team
had a college education,
not even Orville or Wilbur,
and the New York Times
followed them around nowhere.
The difference was Orville and Wilbur
were driven by a cause,
by a purpose, by a belief.
They believed that if they could
figure out this flying machine,
it'll change the course of the world.
Samuel Pierpont Langley was different.
He wanted to be rich and
he wanted to be famous.
He was in pursuit of the result,
he was in pursuit of the riches.
And lo and behold, look what happened.
The people who believed in
the Wright brothers' dream
worked with them with
blood, and sweat, and tears.
The others just worked for the paycheck.
And they tell stories of how
every time the Wright brothers
went out, they would have
to take five sets of parts,
because that's how many
times they would crash
before they came in for supper.
(audience members laughing)
And eventually, on December 17, 1903,
the Wright brothers took flight
and no one was there
to even experience it.
We found out about it a few days later.
And further proof that Langley
was motivated by the wrong thing,
the day the Wright brothers
took flight, he quit.
He could've said, "That's
an amazing discovery, guys.
"Now I will improve upon your
technology," but he didn't.
He wasn't first, he didn't get rich,
he didn't get famous, so he quit.
People don't buy what you
do, they buy why you do it.
And if you talk about what you believe,
you will attract those who
believe what you believe.
People often say that they
think they have their Why.
Well, more than that that they feel it.
That it feels right and they
know they're in the ballpark,
but they're struggling to find the words.
That's okay.
The most important part
about this Why process,
is that, indeed, it feels right.
Remember, the Why exists
in the part of the brain,
the limbic brain that
controls our feelings.
It also controls all our
behavior and decision making,
and so we don't want to
"think" that it's right,
we want to feel that it's right.
And once you have that gut
decision, that that's it,
and you get goosebumps when
you start telling the stories
that you think push you towards your Why,
then you know you have it.
If you start to well up or
have an emotional response,
you definitely know
you're in the ballpark.
Then the trick is to find the words.
And it's the words, it's the ability
to articulate your Why
that makes it actionable.
And so, absolutely, the words will evolve.
The words will adapt and
change, but the meaning cannot.
It's the meaning of those words,
those words that give you
that visceral feeling,
those goosebumps that make you well up.
Whatever the feeling you had
is, that's what's paramount.
But the words you can tweak and change,
absolutely, for the end of time.
I've tweaked my Why multiple
times over the years,
but the meaning of it
and the basic direction
is still exactly the same.
It's like a submarine.
When the captain orders
the submarine to go north,
the submarine doesn't
go in a straight line,
it kind of goes like this, and
your Why is the same thing.
You need to know the
direction it's heading,
but it's okay if it goes like this
as you're tweaking the words,
as long as you're moving
in the right direction.
Learning to start with Why really is,
especially in a business context,
when you're interviewing for a job
or pitching your services to someone,
it really is remarkable.
I get so many letters from people,
all excited that they went into a pitch
or they went into a job interview
and they started with Why,
and they were so excited that
not only did they get the job,
but the person who hired
them actually said,
"We love," dot dot dot,
and they repeat their Why back to them.
They don't talk about their qualifications
or any of these things.
In other words, it really
does drive human behavior.
And the more you get good at
it, the more you start to feel
and see the results of starting with Why.
What you'll find is that
the better you are at
communicating your Why,
people will want to work for you
regardless of the opportunity
that you afford them.
Like, they want to be a part of it.
We do a little thing,
which we've been doing
for years and years and
years, called a give-and-take.
Whenever there's any kind of relationship,
whether it's an outside partnership
or even somebody who joins our team,
we do something called a give-and-take,
where we want somebody to be selfish
and selfless within the relationship.
So not give-and-get, but give-and-take.
So we'll ask them, "What is it
that you have to give to us,
"that you have that you
think that we need,"
and they'll tell us.
And then we'll say, "Great.
"what is it that you
selfishly want from us?"
And we want them to tell us
what they can get from us and what else.
- I believe in that so much, man.
- And when those things match,
you have a balanced relationship.
Well example, I've had it with people.
They'll tell me what they have to offer,
and that's awesome because
that's what I want,
and then they'll say what they have,
what they want to take and they go,
"Oh, I want to work with smart people."
I'm like, "Plenty of smart people.
"What is it you want to take from me?"
They're like, "Oh, I want
to help build something."
"Wonderful, do that anywhere.
"What do you want to
take selfishly from me
"that you can get nowhere else?"
And if they can't answer the question,
I won't engage in a relationship,
and the reason is because, in time,
the relationship is unbalanced.
They're going to be giving,
but they're not taking,
and I don't even know how
to give them what they want.
Then they'll complain they're
not making enough money or,
because it's not balanced.
- That's right.
- Now it's time to put
your Why into action.
Discovering your Why
is just the beginning.
In order to enjoy all the benefits
of having a clearly articulated Why,
you'll need to have the courage
and discipline to use it.
Like Thomas Edison said,
"Vision without execution
is hallucination."
There is an ideal order
for implementing your Why,
though, sometimes reality
does get in the way,
and it all starts with you.
Our natural tendency is to
start with the tangible.
We define our value by what we do,
so it takes practice to start with Why.
Like riding a bicycle, at
first we're unsure, unsteady.
We're in our heads, thinking about
all the things we need to do,
pedal fast, keep enough
speed so we don't fall over.
We have to really concentrate.
We may even fall over,
even scrape our knees,
but we get back on the bike and try again,
and eventually, it becomes natural.
Starting with Why is no different.
At first, it feels awkward.
It may not even work, but with practice
it will become so natural
that you won't even be able
to imagine a time when you couldn't do it.
Just like riding a bicycle.
In time, your Why will act as a filter
for many of the decisions
and choices you make.
It becomes a tool to help you find a job
or seize an opportunity in which
you're more likely to succeed.
It removes a lot of the guessing.
Here's a metaphor to show you what I mean.
It's called the celery test.
We're constantly asking
people for their advice
on what to do or how to do it.
It's like going to a dinner
party and somebody says,
"Do you know what you need?
"You need M&M'S.
"We've done so well with M&M'S,
you've got to use M&M'S."
Somebody else says to us, "Rice milk.
"In this economy, you
have to use rice milk."
Someone else says to us, "KIT KATs.
"You have to use KIT KATs."
And somebody else says to
you, "It's all about celery."
We go to the supermarket
with all this good advice,
from all these smart people
with brilliant case studies,
and we buy everything.
We buy KIT KATs and M&M'S,
celery, and rice milk.
There's a lot of time we
spend at the supermarket,
and a lot of money we
spend at the supermarket.
And when we get to the checkout lane,
we're standing there with all
these products in our hands,
and no one can see what we believe
because we bought everything.
But let's imagine we know our Why.
Let's imagine our Why
is to always be healthy,
and only do things that protect
the health of our bodies.
Now which products do we buy?
Given all the same advice,
from all the same smart people.
This time we only buy celery
and we only buy rice milk.
They're the only two that make sense.
We spend less time and less
money at the supermarket,
and when we're standing there in line
with only celery and only rice milk,
now people can see what we believe.
Somebody walking past can say,
"Hey, I can see that
you're healthy, so am I."
You just attracted an opportunity,
or a referral, or a friend,
simply by saying and doing
the things that you believe.
And the best part is it's scalable.
As soon as I said the Why,
you knew exactly which
products we were going to buy.
This means the more you
can articulate your Why,
the more others will
know what you stand for
and will be able to help you
make the right decisions.
From now on, you will work to ensure
everything you do is a good fit.
If you do too many things
that aren't a good fit,
you'll feel uncomfortable
and people will feel that
you're being inauthentic.
On the other hand, when you start with Why
your ability to stand out, find support,
and work to all your natural
strengths will flourish.
With practice, you will
learn to trust your Why.
You will eventually start to see your job
and the things you do
as ways to breathe life into your cause.
And the better you get at
it, the more you will feel
that your life and everything
you do has purpose.
The best way to implement your
Why is to work at it slowly.
You don't have to do
all the tips we suggest.
What is important is
that you pick up to three
and commit to practicing
and using them now.
- Thank you, guys, so much for watching!
I'd love to know, what did you think?
What did you take from
this video from Simon
that you're going to
immediately apply somehow
to your life or to your business?
Please leave it down
in the comments below.
I'm really excited to see
what you guys have to say.
Thank you guys, again, for watching.
I believe in you,
I hope you continue to
believe in yourself.
And whatever your one word is, much love.
I'll see you soon.